myths about the queen's guards myth one
we're not allowed to move
myth two that we are not real soldiers
myth three that we are not allowed to
talk if these myths were true we
wouldn't be able to carry out our job as
a guardsman
have you ever wondered what a soldier
eats in the field in front of me i've
got my next 24 hours of rations
let's have a look for breakfast i'm
having some natural muesli
just throwing a bit of water and it's
good to go for lunch we have some bean
and pasta salad
this can be eaten hot or cold for my
dinner i'll be having a vegetable corner
and a nice cherry turnover as a pudding
the ration also comes with a bunch of
snacks
such as fruit juice peanuts
biscuit browns oat biscuits
and a nice cereal bar to chow all down
come to the spork
and afterwards you might need a bit of
toilet roll this is just one of the
menus
there's loads of others so tomorrow i'll
be having something different
did you know when the queen is in
residence there are four guardsmen out
on sag instead of two
outside the next
oh
what are you doing
[Laughter]
this is part one of army slang
uh buck she so buck shoes when you get
something for free so for example
someone who's just left i just got this
game off of them buckshie
gipping so gippin's when something's
horrible or hard so for example if you
just done a circuit
the circuit is skipping this is the last
one of part one
so gash for example
so i've just picked up the gas did you
know the carrying on horseback got high
points during the inspection
and the cavalrymen on foot didn't do so
well
[Music]
[Music]
chad
please
you